it was a fire like no other
a burning tower that will become a
symbol that something in Britain had
gone wrong nine months on we've analysed
the events of the 14th of June in a way
never done before using this digital
model of the Grenfell tower the team
behind it is called forensic
architecture a group of academic
researchers who investigate human rights
violations across the world this is
their first project in the UK in
collaboration with Sky News they've used
our TV footage from the night witness
testimony and mobile phone data to
recreate what people would have seen and
heard and this becomes the sort of base
on which we can overlay footage from
social media and from new sites like
yourself that have supplied us with
footage and so that we can then
understand in 3d space and in time as
well what's happening and what unfolded
in what order on the night this digital
timeline will cover eight hours of the
fire minute by minute
researchers are collecting hundreds of
stories of the night and asking the
community for any material they have to
make the model as detailed as possible
this will provide a unique and
independent account which forensic
architecture say could be used in the
public inquiry we realized that this was
an event unprecedented in British
history and in London's history and we
resolved that there must be a way that
we could make a unique contribution to
the public understanding of this
catastrophe it will be a historical tool
this will be a tool that we hope will be
the most complete publicly available
record of the circumstances of the night
of the fire and it's a record that will
be built from all the publicly available
information
we hope and that we're asking the public
will share with us one person with a
powerful story to share is Jackie Hays
she lives right next to the tower she
has done for 40 years she was outside
that night and witnessed the flames
engulf the building when you watch it
just go up in seconds
it didn't fit it just didn't fit with
what what your mind knows should be
happening and then the people scream and
limb realizing that they couldn't get
out and shouting through the windows
when a waving their phones screaming and
at one point we were standing on the
lane and we saw two people just fly out
of the window someone else watching in
panic was 27 year old Christopher he'd
been working late and returned home to
grenfell around 1:00 a.m. he lived on
the 10th floor of the tower with his
father Antonio who was asleep inside
when I saw it the first time before I'd
already lost him so that's why the
reason I couldn't straight away and he
woke up
luckily the tower had been home to
Antonio for almost 30 years he managed
to survive in his flat for five hours
doing all he could to stay safe as the
fire spread around him the moment I
opened the door a lot of smoke came in
very hot very very strong very dark
pitch dark and their allies hold on a
second here it in you're in big trouble
so I closed the door quickly I went to
the bathroom and I rinsed my eyes a
little bit and then Christopher from
downstairs
he sent me a picture of the tower
burning and it was not like a small fire
it was like the whole side of the tower
was burning so and then I said okay he
have to make sure that you know now you
do the right thing
because if you do something wrong you
might not be able to get out of life
above Antonio on the 22nd floor with a
shoe care family Nadia and her husband
Bassam lived in flat 193 with their
three children
store was Nadia's mother they called 999
for help up to eight times and were told
to stay inside the whole family died
that night I lost my mother my sister my
brother-in-law and their kids three kids
they were the best thing I ever had in
my life fun
the last contact Nabeel had with his
sister was a phone message at 2:41 in
the morning it was like to say goodbye
that's the way of it was a text message
yeah what did it say basically you'll
say behind a bill I'm in the tower
there's a fire just you know just what
does it take
because I was asleep at the time say
it's big died that year you know and
that was it basically
the bill believes his family will cause
further distress by a police helicopter
used during the fire this photograph
shows his sister Nadia with a makeshift
flag waving for help as the fire raged
Nabil thinks the helicopter gave
residents hope they were going to be
rescued he's made a formal complaint
which the Metropolitan Police are
investigating they were deceived and
it's it was unacceptable you know it's
what they were doing is it's not right
you shouldn't have been there at the
time
perhaps most controversial that night
though was the instruction by emergency
services for residents to wait inside
their flats Antonio did stay put and he
was saved but he believes he was lucky
he was on a lower floor he thinks those
above him should have been told to leave
nobody knew is that how fragile the
outside of the building was and that the
fire was spreading and and and and
burning so quickly that in that case
especially the top floor you know it you
have to go out you have to go out if I
had seen the fire you know coming
towards me if I had been in you know on
the top floor as well okay when you see
this it's you know it's a death trap Sky
News has learned there were runes on
every floor of the tower that weren't
damaged by the fire firefighters have
told us these small rooms toward the bin
chutes where residents got rid of their
rubbish they had a fire door but no
windows and we've been told were
untouched by smoke the Metropolitan
Police were in control of the tower
while it remains a crime scene refused
to comment while their investigation is
ongoing
on the night of the fire Antonio was one
of the last people to leave the building
alive he was finally rescued at 6:30 in
the morning I was leaning my elbow onto
the handrail
so I because I could not see anything
don't forget that I was totally blind
because of the towel that I had on me
and so basically you know we went down
very well synchronized and as we've
reached the lower part of the tower then
I could hear voices and in no time we
were downstairs a lot I remember lots of
people for everyone who experienced the
horror of that night getting
transparency and the truth is vital it's
our Labor's it's our friends you know
people who we've known long enough to be
found to be like family and that that's
why it was the whole estate that felt it
that day it wasn't just the tower
burning it was we are on fire 71 people
lost their lives in the ground felt our
fire and hundreds of others were left
homeless Antonio and Christopher have
now moved out of a hotel in inter
temporary accommodation appreciating the
simple things they've missed but like
all those affected by the fire the most
pressing concern is getting the answers
they need and making sure a tragedy like
grenfell never happens again
they must come up with the proper answer
and they must come up with the justice
we need to stand up for ourselves and we
need to make sure that we're not just
left to live in vulnerable unsafe
conditions we have to stand up now I
want to make sure that they never figure
out that they always remembered forever